gets you down as long as the eight to  twelve core people in my life are  healthy I struggle to really get down I  just don't know how to do it and so when  you live your life that way losing a big  account or somebody calling you out is  just not that painful you just put it  into context I usually just like you  know like take it you know like you know  what me this is so interesting I think  you find this interesting my favorite  scene in movies is always when somebody  gets punched in the mouth and they take  the punch they spit their tooth out and  then they look back at the other person  I don't know if you've seen that there's  always some version of that scene that's  who I am as a [ __ ] human being like  I'm built to get punched in the mouth  I'm gonna spit my friend mm I'm gonna  look right back at you and be like now  what [ __ ]